The next Dune movie comes out in November
– and new trailers and interviews reveal
new characters like Feyd-Rautha Harkonnen
and Princess Irulan.
So who are these characters, what’s happening
in the trailer, and how does it compare to
the book?
This video has no big spoilers – just some
background info from the book and from interviews
to get us ready for Dune Part Two.
So in the first Dune movie, the Atreides took
over the planet Arrakis.
In the deserts of Arrakis are giant sandworms,
and a precious resource called spice.
The Atreides were attacked and defeated by
the Harkonnens, with the help of the Emperor’s
soldiers.
So Paul and Jessica Atreides escaped and joined
the Fremen in the desert.
Paul had visions of the future – seeing
himself as a religious leader, unleashing
a terrible holy war.
Director Denis Villeneuve says the first Dune
movie is “contemplative” – it’s slow.
But that the next movie, Part Two, is an “action-packed,
epic war movie”.
The trailer shows Paul and Chani fighting
Harkonnen soldiers.
The trailer says ‘long live the fighters’,
which is a Fremen battle cry – this is a
war for control of Arrakis.
But amidst the violence and sci fi shenanigans,
Villeneuve centres the story on the human
relationship of Paul and Chani.
In the trailer, Paul and Chani kiss, and say
that they will stay together – which is
similar to a line in the book.
Chani’s actor Zendaya says that despite
the “intense circumstances”, these are
just “two young people”, “trying to
grow up and fall in love”.
She draws on relatable feelings of teenage
awkwardness.
And there are awkward moments in the book
– Chani makes Paul blush, and feel embarrassed
when they meet.
Paul and Chani are from different cultures,
they’re literally from different planets,
so they have misunderstandings, and they learn
from each other.
In the trailer, Paul compares the sand dunes
of Arrakis to the ocean waves of his homeworld,
Caladan.
This is based on a bit in the book, when Chani
asks about the waters of Paul’s birthworld.
In the trailer, Paul talks about swimming
and diving in water, and Chani can’t imagine
that’s even possible, because water is so
rare on Arrakis.
That’s based on a different bit from the
book, where Paul explains what drowning and
boats are to a woman.
In the Dune book, we don’t get to see much
of the beginning of Paul and Chani’s relationship.
The new movie explores their relationship
more, using bits from the book to inspire
new scenes.
The trailer shows a soldier burning corpses
– they look like dead Atreides from the
battle in the first movie.
Previously, Paul had visions of burning corpses,
and they were connected with his vision of
a holy war.
Paul sees death in his future and in his past.
We see a portrait of Paul’s dead father
Leto burning.
In the first movie, we saw a portrait of Leto’s
father, the Old Duke.
The Old Duke died when he faced a bull in
an arena and was killed.
Like how Leto faced the Harkonnens on Arrakis,
and was killed.
Now Paul is facing danger – will he be killed,
like his father and grandfather before him?
In the trailer, Jessica says Leto didn’t
believe in revenge.
Leto spoke of honour, honesty, and morality.
Will Paul live up to these ideals?
In the book, Leto says that if they compromise
their morals to survive, the honourable Atreides
banner “could come to mean many evil things”.
The trailer shows Jessica in a basket with
some Fremen, as they ride on a sandworm – you
can see this guy steering the sandworm with
ropes.
Cause the Fremen use sandworms to travel,
and certain important people ride worms in
a palanquin, this special basket.
We see Jessica with blue eyes, which is caused
by spice – you can see spice on her nose,
like she’s been snorting it.
We see Jessica in fancy costumes, and she
has markings on her face, similar to this
vision Paul had in the first movie.
Villeneuve says these markings are tattoos,
linked with the prophecy of the Lisan al-Gaib,
the messiah who will save the Fremen.
Some Fremen believe that Jessica and Paul
fit this prophecy, that they are the chosen
ones.
These markings are on Jessica’s clothes
as well as her face, she is physically cloaking
herself in this prophecy, playing the role
of messiah.
Jessica wants the Fremen to believe that she
and Paul are the chosen ones so that she can
use the Fremen to help her and Paul.
And Paul doesn’t like this.
In the trailer, Jessica says they give “hope”
to the Fremen, but Paul says “That's not
hope”.
Because in the first movie we learned that
the Fremen prophecy is at least partly a lie.
The Bene Gesserit planted this prophecy on
Arrakis as a tool to control the Fremen.
Paul doesn’t want to exploit Fremen religion
– though, he does need the Fremen’s help
to survive on Arrakis.
And there is some truth to the prophecy – Paul
does have real power to see the future.
Jessica believes that Paul may be the Kwisatz
Haderach, a superhuman created by the Bene
Gesserit breeding program.
So.. it’s complicated – Paul and Jessica
are playing with powerful dangerous forces
of religion, politics, visions and predictions,
and Paul knows this could lead to terrible
destruction.
We see a new character, played by Florence
Pugh – this is Princess Irulan Corrino.
Irulan is the daughter of the Emperor of the
Universe, Shaddam Corrino.
We haven’t seen the Emperor yet, but he’ll
be played by Christopher Walken.
Irulan is described in the book as tall blonde
and beautiful, confident, and intelligent.
Irulan has been trained by the Bene Gesserit
– so she has powers of perception, control,
and combat.
In the Dune book, each chapter starts with
a quote from a book written by Irulan.
Irulan writes about history, and philosophy,
giving us worldbuilding details and thematic
ideas for each chapter.
Irulan also writes about her own life.
As the Emperor’s daughter, Irulan had a..
difficult childhood – she writes “A Royal
Family is not like other families” – in
her home, political plots and intrigues were
“constant and oppressive”, and even her
own father was a potential threat to her.
Irulan is a minor character in the Dune book.
But the new movie gives her a bigger role.
In the trailer, she says that the fall of
House Atreides is a dark secret, and she wonders
if Paul might still be alive.
Cause the Harkonnens tried to kill the Atreides
secretly, to make them “die in the dark”.
>Despite the fact that the Baron promised
the Bene Gesserit that he wouldn’t kill
Paul and Jessica.
The Harkonnens think Paul and Jessica are
dead – they saw them fly into a storm.
But it looks like Irulan wants to find the
truth.
In the trailer, someone approaches a Fremen,
then we see Irulan in a.. chainmail outfit.
Is Irulan on Arrakis, hunting for Paul?
That would be a big change from the book – but
as a Bene Gesserit, Irulan would have the
skills to infiltrate, spy and fight.
The Dune TV adaptation on the Sci Fi Channel
also gave Irulan an investigation plotline
– and gave her a similar outfit, maybe they’re
drawing inspiration here.
This captured Fremen might be the character
Shishakli.
Shishakli is a man in the book, but played
by Souheila Yacoub in the movie.
These dead birds might have been an attempt
by Shisashakli to send a message, because
Fremen use birds and bats to send messages,
but maybe these soldiers stopped her.
We don’t know exactly what’s happening
here, but it looks like Princess Irulan has
a bigger role in this movie that she has in
the Dune book.
Another new character is Feyd-Rautha Harkonnen,
played by Austin Butler.
Feyd-Rautha is a nephew of the Baron Vladimir
Harkonnen, and is the brother of “Beast”
Rabban.
Feyd is the Baron’s favourite nephew.
Because Beast Rabban is.. a dumb brute, but
Feyd is smart, scheming, ruthless.
In the book, Feyd-Rautha is seventeen years
old, a sullen teenager with dark hair in ringlets,
though in the new movie he’s bald.
All the Harkonnens are bald and pale in the
Villeneuve movies, because their planet Giedi
Prime is ultra-industrialised, polluted, and
unnatural, so the Harkonnens are sickly, pale,
and.. >bald.
Feyd-Rautha has a sensual, effeminate quality
in the book – he has full pouting lips,
and wears tight black clothes.
So in the 70s, filmmaker Jodorowsky wanted
Mick Jagger from the Rolling Stones to play
Feyd.
In the 80s David Lynch movie, he was played
by Sting.
So Feyd-Rautha is like a cross between a sexy
rockstar and a psycho serial killer.
Villeneuve says Feyd is charismatic, narcissistic,
strategic, and cruel.
In the trailer, Feyd enters an arena, and
the curving shapes of this opening look like
a vulva or a mouth – Harkonnen architecture
is about consuming, swallowing everything
into the belly of the whale, because the Harkonnens
devour resources, people, and worlds.
[Jodorwsky clip]
Feyd fights a gladiator in the arena, and
everything’s shot in stark black and white.
Villeneuve said he loves the colour black,
and has long dreamed of “a world made out
of one color with a lot of sensuality and
high design”.
The man who Feyd is fighting is Lieutenant
Lanville – this guy is a background character
in the first movie, an Atreides soldier played
by Roger Yuan, the movies’ fight coordinator.
So it looks like Lanville was captured in
the battle in the first movie, and has now
been enslaved by the Harkonnens, forced to
fight for sport.
You can see scars on Lanville’s back – cause
the Harkonnens whip their slaves with a particular
vine that leaves painful scars – Gurney
has scar on his face from when he was a Harkonnen
slave.
Also, in the background of this shot, we can
see creepy dancing figures with weirdly shaped
hats, or.. heads.
So this fight scene between Feyd and Lanville
will be visually striking.
Later, we see Feyd facing Paul.
Paul holds his knife to his head, which is
the same Atreides salute that Duncan used
before his death.
Then Paul says “May thy knife chip and shatter”.
Which is what Jamis said to Paul in the first
movie.
So Paul learns from his Atreides teachers,
and from his Fremen teachers, and will use
those deadly lessons against Feyd.
In seems that Paul and Feyd are destined to
clash.
Cause the Atreides and the Harkonnens are
opposites – the Atreides use self-control
to master their own minds, while the Harkonnens
are beasts ruled by their greed, lust, and
rage.
We see Feyd roar like an animal.
This is what Gaius talked about in the first
movie – is Paul a human, or an animal?
When Paul fights Feyd-Rautha, he confronts
the beast within himself.
So we’ll see a lot more of the Harkonnens
in Dune Part Two.
This promo shot shows the Baron in a bath.
He might still be recovering from Leto’s
poison attack in the last movie.
Villenueve says the Baron is like a hippopotamus
cause he’s “more comfortable in liquid”
because of his weight.
In this shot, “he’s smoking spice”,
which is wonderfully indulgent.
The Baron is a sensualist who craves pleasure
through food and sex and every kind of physical
stimulation.
The books don’t mention him taking baths
or smoking, but this is fitting for his personality.
Another new character is Lady Margot Fenring,
played by Léa Seydoux.
Margot watches Feyd-Rautha fight in the arena,
and the two have a closer encounter later.
There’s also this shot of what might be
Margot arriving on the Harkonen planet Giedi
Prime – cause the surface of Giedi Prime
is full of “bitter oil” and pollution,
which is kinda how this black dirt looks.
But who is Margot?
Margot is a Bene Gesserit, like Irulan and
Jessica, so she has powers of perception,
combat, and control.
She’s described in the books as “golden-haired
and willowy”, “perfection of figure”.
Margot is married to Count Hasimir Fenring
– who might be played by Tim Blake Nelson,
it’s not confirmed yet.
But Hasimir is a politician and a friend of
the Emperor Shaddam.
In the book, Hasimir and Margot worked for
the Emperor on Arrakis, smuggling spies and
assassins.
They lived in the Arrakeen governor’s mansion
– until the Atreides moved in.
And when the Atreides arrive, Jessica finds
a note from Margot warning her about the Harkonnens.
So it seems like Margot wants to help the
Atreides, though her husband Hasimir works
for the Emperor, who wants to destroy the
Atreides, and the Bene Gesserit have their
own plans with Margot.
So the Fenrings have complicated relationships
with the great powers of this universe.
Whose side are they on?
Villeneuve says Margot is a “secret agent”,
and she’s “a character full of surprises”.
Gurney Halleck appears in the trailer.
Remember, Gurney is one of Paul’s teachers,
and is one of the greatest warriors in the
universe.
Last time we saw Gurney, he fought against
the Harkonnens in battle.
And in the book, >we don’t know for a while
if Gurney survives that battle.
But the trailer shows that Gurney lives to
fight again.
His hair is longer now, so it looks like some
time has passed.
Villeneuve says Gurney “has come back to
avenge his friends”.
The trailer also shows some Fremen going through
a fancy door underground, maybe the entrance
to a sietch, a Fremen settlement.
It’s unlocked with some kind of finger scanner.
In the book, Jessica opens a lock that reads
that reads the shape of her hand, so maybe
this is a similar technology.
The machine also looks similar to the pain
box from the first movie – Dune often repeats
this imagery of facing pain, facing a test,
so that you can learn and improve yourself.
So the centrepiece of the trailer is Paul
facing a deadly test – trying to ride a
sandworm.
In Fremen culture, riding a worm for the first
time is a coming of age ritual, this is how
a boy becomes a man.
The phallic worm suggests sexual maturity.
[show pic of Freud and Feyd-vulva].
There’s also religious connotations, cause
the sandworms are like gods to the Fremen,
they call them Shai-Hulud and maker.
The way it works is, the Fremen plants a device
called thumper.
The thumper makes a rhythmic noise which vibrates
through the ground and attracts a sandworm.
Then the Fremen uses these maker hooks to
climb up onto the worm.
When they stick a hook under the sandworm’s
scales, the sandworm rolls and turns to keep
its exposed skin away from the ground.
So by pulling the hooks, a Fremen can steer
the worm, and travel where they wish.
But getting on top of the giant moving worm
is very dangerous, it’s easy to fall and
get crushed.
So facing the worm is like the Old Duke facing
the bull, Leto facing the Baron, Paul facing
the gom jabbar, the hunter-seeker, and Jamis
– this is a deadly test that Paul can only
survive through mastery of his body and mind.
In the trailer, Stilgar tells Paul to keep
his worm ride “simple”, “Nothing fancy”,
just do it safely.
Stilgar says the same thing in the book.
Cause sometimes young Fremen get too excited
and proud, and they show off with tricks like
dancing and doing handstands atop the worm.
>Paul might like to show off in front of his
crush Chani.
But Stilgar doesn’t want Paul to take a
dumb risk and get killed.
In the trailer, Paul falls and almost dies.
But he rises again, and rides the worm.
He is now a man, a full Fremen.
And the Fremen are elated.
Maybe Paul really is the messiah.
The trailer ends with a huge crowd of Fremen
cheering Paul.
It feels triumphant.
But remember Paul’s visions in the first
movie, of the cheering crowds that bring destruction
– he sees “a holy war spreading across
the universe like unquenchable fire”, “A
war in my name!”.
In the book, Kynes thinks that “No more
terrible disaster could befall your people
than for them to fall into the hands of a
Hero”.
To go deeper into Dune, check out these videos
on Nebula.
Tale Foundry’s video about the genre of
Dune argues that the story finds the fantastical
not in magic but it humanity itself . And
Thomas Flight explains some techniques used
in the first Dune movie’s sound design . Both
these videos are only available on Nebula,
an independent creator-owned video site where
we don’t have to worry about demonetisation,
or the algorithm.
Nebula also has classes with people like Tom
Nicholas teaching how they make videos.
And Nebula is where Lindsay Ellis exclusively
posts her videos now, including an essay on
the adaptation of The Lord of the Rings, and
a new video on Guy Fieri.
There’s a lot of great content on Nebula.
And using the link below, you can get 40%
off an annual plan – you’ll get exclusive
content, and support independent creators,
including Alt Shift X.
Thanks for watching.
And thanks to the Patrons, including ceNe,
Jarin, Caleb Mattingly, Cristobal Tineo, and
Izaac B. Cheers.